bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardant
en direct notre grand témoin ce soir
c'est vous Sonia Mabrouk bonsoir bonsoir
et merci journaliste le matin sur Europe
1 le midi sur cnews et de nouveau en
librairie depuis quelques jours vous
publiez reconquérir le sacré aux
éditions de l'Observatoire c'est un
témoignage intime autant qu'un pamphlet
sur l'oxydant désenchantée il est urgent
de reconquérir ce sacré il en va même de
la survie de nos sociétés modernes c'est
dit on va en parler c'est à la fois
stimulant et c'est assez déroutant par
moment on y revient tout à l'heure mais
on commence avec l'atome double
actualité à l'Assemblée les députés
débat du projet de loi sur le nucléaire
pour relancer la filière en même temps
qu'ils enquêtes au Palais Bourbon sur
les responsabilités du retard français
alors entre les erreurs du passé et les
investissements pharaoniques à venir à
ton
véritablement et bien tirer les bilans
nécessaires c'est notre grand débat dans
un instant avant avec nos invités ités
avant de retrouver aux alentours de
20h15 les parties pris de nos affranchis
et puis Bourbon Express bien sûr
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée vous me
suivez Sonia Mabo mais grand plaisir ça
vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
vive les centrales nucléaires qu'il
semble loin le temps où l'on fermait
Fessenheim presque toutes les forces
politiques ne jurent plus désormais que
par l'atome la guerre en Ukraine bien
sûr la crise climatique sont passées par
là c'est dans ce contexte que les
députés examinent depuis hier dans
l'hémicycle le projet de loi sur le
nucléaire bonsoir Charles Rodwell et
bienvenue sur ce plateau député
renaissance des Yvelines membre de cette
commission d'enquête à l'Assemblée très
politique dont le titre c'est d'établir
les raisons je cite de la perte de
souveraineté d'indépendance énergétique
de la France elle s'apprête à
auditionner François Hollande et Nicolas
Sarkozy jeudi prochain on y reviendra
bonsoir Charles Fournier bienvenue sur
ce plateau vous êtes député Europe
Écologie Les Verts d'Indre-et-Loire
opposés à ce texte l'une des dernières
forces politiques à dire non au
nucléaire on verra si vous vous sentez
isolé ou pas bonsoir Géraldine Wessner
bienvenue visage familier de cette
émission vous êtes journaliste au point
pour lequel vous suivez des questions
énergétiques je signale sortir du
nucléaire c'était dans la collection
pour les nuls ça fait débats enfin
bonsoir Bernard Laponche bienvenue sur
ce plateau vous êtes physicien nucléaire
ancien membre du Commissariat à
l'énergie atomique et puis vous vous
connaissez la filière de l'intérieur
mais vous êtes aujourd'hui très critique
sur le nucléaire vous nous direz
pourquoi Sonia Mabrouk je suis sûr que
ça vous intéresse cette question donc
n'hésitez pas à intervenir quand vous le
souhaitez la relance du nucléaire on l'a
compris c'est à la fois une course de
vitesse mais aussi une course
d'obstacles et ce projet de loi a pour
objectif de les lever alors comment il a
de 100 secondes pour nous le dire dans
son billet Stéphane blackovski le chrono
de Blacko tout de suite
et je me retourne pour vous accueillir
ces fans du haut de votre estrade
bonsoir Myriam bonsoir à toutes et tous
ça y est le moment nucléaire est arrivé
oui alors si vous permettez on commence
par un petit flashback c'était il y a 5
ans nous étions en 2018 et voilà ce que
les Français pensaient du nucléaire 2018
c'est l'année où président Macron décide
de fermer 14 centrales nucléaires à long
terme et plus de 60% des Français disent
à l'époque oui le nucléaire n'est pas
vraiment une énergie d'avenir 5 ans plus
tard on en est où les mêmes Français
pensent à 70% que les nucléaires est
plutôt une énergie d'avenir d'ailleurs
le Président lui aussi a changé la vie
puisque au lieu de vouloir fermer 14
centrales il voudrait en construire 14
donc par contre ce petit revirement fait
qu'on a peut-être pris un peu de retard
donc quel est l'objet de ce projet de
loi et bien Guillaume kasbariian le
résume en 6 secondes en l'écoute
c'est exactement l'objet de ce projet de
loi accélérer accélérer accélérer la
base de la pédagogie c'est la répétition
si vous n'avez pas compris ce que
voulait le président de ma conseille
vous n'avez pas été attentif à ce que
disait Guillaume kasbariante allez vite
évidemment c'est plutôt une bonne chose
mais attention à cette confusion assez
fréquente et souvent dénoncée d'ailleurs
qui consiste à confondre la vitesse avec
mais oui bien sûr avec la précipitation
donc forcément de ce point de vue le
gouvernement a soulé quelques
inquiétudes parce que l'une de ces
décisions consiste à fusionner les deux
à dire deux systèmes autorité c'est pas
exactement le terme qui jusque là
s'occupait de la sécurité du nucléaire
alors cette première instance c'était
voilà on va la voir la SN qui était donc
qui est toujours l'autorité de la sortie
du clair on dit que c'est le gendarme
parce qu'ils sont indépendants du
pouvoir politique ici il décide par
exemple de fermer une centrale pour des
raisons de sécurité même le président ne
peut pas les en empêcher mais pour
fonder leur décision ils ont besoin de
l'autre pied de l'autre jambe du système
l'IRSN qui eux rassemble les experts
mais qui n'ont pas la même indépendance
qui travaille sous tutelle des
ministères alors bien sûr la question
c'est de savoir est-ce que c'est grave
de fusionner ces deux instances pour des
raisons de sécurité et bien je vais
lancer je ne peux pas vous le
dire vous avez plein d'experts sur le
sujet mais ce que je ressens moi c'est
que évidemment changer le système de
surveillance du nucléaire au moment où
on relance le nucléaire c'est un peu
flippant d'ailleurs Benjamin saint tuile
est un peu d'accord avec moi il est
député Elliot
je le dis d'autant plus tranquillement
que je fais partie des élus qui sont
considérés pro nucléaires ce qui veulent
accélérer les procédures doivent
considérer à quel point l'accélération
peut engendrer une crainte sur la
question de la sûreté
alors de fait évidemment ceux qui sont
ennucléaires sont les premiers à tirer
le signal d'alarme à l'Assemblée parce
que il s'agit pas seulement de
construire 14 nouveaux réacteurs on veut
aussi prolonger la vie des des vieux
réacteurs qui étaient prêts à partir à
la retraite et donc forcément Julia
l'arnos personne ne contredit qui est
député européenchéologie des Verts elle
tire le signal d'alarme je voulais
être raisonnable de décaler l'âge de
départ à la retraite de nos vieux
réacteurs alors qu'il souffre déjà de
leur vieillissement j'en veux pour
preuve la découverte nouvelle fissure
d'une ampleur inégalée sur les sites de
panique 4 noms donc voilà il
l'opposition existe à l'Assemblée mais
reste un peu minoritaire contrairement à
la réforme des retraites le gouvernement
n'est pas trop inquiet quant à savoir si
le projet doit sa voter RN est pour LR
sont pour Renaissance son pour même les
communistes sont pour bon le compte est
bon cela dit il y a peut-être aussi une
raison pour laquelle la droite est en
soutien de ce projet c'est que c'est
quand même un truc cocorico pour la
France le nucléaire c'est un peu notre
spécialité et c'est notamment un sujet
où en tout cas c'est ce que dit notre
ingénieur nucléaire préféré rapporte du
projet de loi on a pris un peu d'avance
sur les Allemands on écoute mode Bergeon
il reste en Allemagne 40 gigawatts de
charbon soit l'équivalent des deux tiers
de notre parc nucléaire et nos voisins
ont annoncé la semaine dernière le
doublement de leurs capacité en gaz avec
des impacts sur le climat évident
macronction et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le dire c'est que les vrais
écologistes aujourd'hui sont pros
nucléaires bon ben voilà j'ai fait de
mon mieux je me suis un peu trompé sur
le nom de mode braise pour les contes
donc il y a un peu tous les arguments
donc j'ai tout mis dans le shaker donc
il reste plus qu'à Remer pour faire un
bon débat mais ça
on va tâcher Charles Rodwell déjà sur le
moment on est dans un moment nucléaire
et c'est quand même incroyable en termes
de renversement d'opinion est-ce que
c'est forcément pour vous une très bonne
nouvelle alors nous on prend pas les
décisions qu'on s'apprête à prendre sur
le projet de loi nucléaire si les voté
selon l'attitude ou selon le moment de
l'opinion publique moi je soutiens ce
projet de loi nucléaire parce que il
permet de revitaliser de relancer une
filière qui nous permet d'avoir une
énergie conséquente ça aide porté par
les Français quand même
pilotable la comparaison je crois avec
l'Allemagne est bonne il ne s'agit pas à
faire du tout nucléaire mais le tout
renouvelable qui déportés par les
Allemands pendant des années résulte à
plus de gaz naturel et plus de charbon
notre conviction et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a voté un projet de loi sur
les EnR et désormais un projet de loi
sur le nucléaire c'est de promouvoir
c'est de développer les deux types
d'énergie des carbonées car nous pensons
que c'est ce mix c'est pour ça que vous
accélérez d'ailleurs qui pourra
s'assurer les procédures des deux aussi
bien il y a eu un texte énergies
renouvelable et maintenant on simplifie
maintenant traiter le nucléaire Charles
Fournier vous avez entendu mode région
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez au fond
les vrais écologistes sont les
pronucléaires vous êtes quand même très
seul quand on regarde les forces
politiques mis à part LFI aujourd'hui
vous êtes avec les les écologistes les
seuls à vous battre contre le nucléaire
même en Allemagne une partie des vers
allemand s'est résignée à garder un tout
petit peu de nucléaire les trois
dernières centrales ont été prolongées
en Allemagne est-ce que vous ass cet
isolement aujourd'hui oui nous assumons
cette position d'ailleurs je voudrais
dire que les socialistes sont partagés
sur le sujet et ont évolué dans leur
position pour ce qui nous concerne c'est
évidemment une lutte de longue date et
nous avons derrière cette lutte un sujet
majeur qui est celui de notre addiction
aux énergies fossiles avant de parler du
nucléaire qui représente 3 % de la part
mondiale dans le mix et énergétique par
électrique le risque énergétique et là
il s'agit de l'avenir bien sûr de la
France dans le monde je voudrais juste
le dire c'est justement une discussion
très française et qu'il faut regarder je
veux bien qu'on parle de l'Allemagne en
Allemagne il faudrait se rappeler que le
niveau d'utilisation du charbon était
tellement haut qu'aujourd'hui évidemment
ils sont toujours plus haut que nous
mais ils ont diminué cette part
conjoncturellement parce qu'ils sont
soumis aux mêmes difficultés
d'indépendance et de dépendance au gaz
russe ils ont une augmentation du
charbon mais c'est conjoncturelle dans
le même temps
exploser les énergies renouvelables près
de 40%, on va pas faire la comparaison
même vos électeurs 53% des électeurs
estime que c'est une énergie d'avenir
est-ce que c'est pas une forme d'échec
pour vous aussi non je crois que
d'ailleurs l'opinion évolue puisqu'elle
a été très favorable il y a quelques
temps elle est en ce moment très
défavorable il y a quelques temps là
elle est très favorable dans le moment
les choses ne sont pas terminées notre
exercice à nous c'est justement
d'expliquer tous les enjeux qu'il y a
autour du nucléaire qui s'agisse des
enjeux de résilience face au changement
climatique qui s'agisse des enjeux de
coups faramineux de toutes les
opérations on parlait tout à l'heure par
exemple de l'enfouissement des déchets
on a créé 6 Go calquer sur les centrales
actuelles mon a pas encore parlé des
futurs centrales que nous allons créer
et donc il faudra recréer un futur si
géo ces 5 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires sur la table et donc les
problèmes d'eau les problèmes des rêves
bleuement climatiques
de sécurité la sécurité en premier mais
on entend toujours le coup le
dérèglement sujet le sujet est toujours
là mais la résidence est un sujet de
sécurité aussi quand on parle de
submersion marine comme ça nous avons
connu à Fukushima et qu'on va nous
placer nos réacteurs sur des traits de
côtes qui vont reculer il y a un vrai
sujet nous avions un amendement
là-dessus qui est l'article qui concerne
la sécurisation juridique du
développement du nucléaire sur le
littoral on a même posé un amant le
Sénat les écologistes sont posées en
amont pour interdire la construction
dans des eaux inondables et la ministre
peut revenir dessus ça c'est absolument
et responsable parce que c'est un sujet
qui monte énormément dans le débat
contemporain puisque on parle beaucoup
de la pénurie d'eau de la sécheresse
Géraldine bessner compatibilité entre
dérèglements climatique et nucléaire on
sait que c'est compatible pour la simple
raison que la plus grande centrale aux
États-Unis elle tourne en plein désert
de l'Arizona à Palo Verde elle est
alimentée par les eaux usées de la ville
de Phoenix la vraie question qui se pose
c'est quel type de centrale on met et à
quel endroit il y a deux types de
réacteurs un des réactiver à cycles
ouverts qui prélève à peu près 50 mètres
cubes d'eau dans la rivière la rejette
et du coup réchauffe de 4 à degrés les
eaux de la rivière ça peut poser des
problèmes aux écosystèmes celle là
effectivement risque à l'avenir de
devoir disparaître maintenant des
centrales à cycle fermé prélèvent très
peu d'eau et parmi les 6 pères
ou est-ce qu'on les met ils vont aller
de le faire là où il y a des centrales
déjà existent la vraie question qui
n'est pas dans ce texte et qui n'est pas
encore venu dans le débat public qui à
mon sens n'est pas celle qu'on vient
d'évoquer la vraie question va être
celle du foncier effectivement si il
s'agit de construire six nouveaux
réacteurs alors on a déjà les sites sur
les sites existants maintenant
[Musique]
j'aimerais qu'il m'explique où on les
met parce que il va y avoir là un vrai
débat un vrai problème de localisation
et de foncier perma la ponche vous qui
connaissez bien la filière et qui est
devenu très critique qu'est-ce que vous
redoutez le plus avec cette relance du
nucléaire
on peut parler du nucléaire en général
et très rapidement je vais vous dire
un le risque d'accident
les autorités de sûreté nucléaires
françaises ont répété l'une après
l'autre que l'accident grave était
possible en France donc c'est déjà une
question vis-à-vis du public qui sont de
compte que cette possibilité
deuxièmement les déchets qui sont
produits par par ce fonctionnement des
centrales nucléaires et en particulier
par le retraitement des combustibles
irradiés troisièmement du fait de la
production du plutonium les risques de
prolifération c'est-à-dire le fait de
développer une éclair civile dans un
pays permet de développer le nucléaire
militaire alors quatrièmement les coûts
qui augmentent de façon considérable
alors que les coûts des énergies
renouvelables diminue
cinquièmement les risques climatiques on
pourra y revenir et sixièmement on peut
faire autre chose mais ce qui
m'intéresse aujourd'hui on peut faire
autre chose on peut faire du tout
renouvelable absolument d'ailleurs dans
le monde entier c'est ce qu'on fait en
Allemagne
je sais que l'avenir du climat c'est
plus votre sujet c'est encore le sujet
de nos générations et des générations
plus jeunes quand on voit l'Allemagne
rouvrir 26 centrales à charbon vous ne
pouvez pas dire oui on sait faire et on
sait faire tout de suite chère madame je
ne vous ai pas interrompu je vous
demande de me laisser parler et je vais
venir au sujet de la loi d'accélération
et du sujet de la Sûreté Nucléaire
l'organisation de la sûreté nucléaire il
n'est pas une question de la fusion des
deux entités mais peut-être pour
répondre à Géraldine on y vient tout de
suite pour répondre à Géraldine Wessner
sur la question de l'exemple allemand
qui a voulu faire du renouvelable
qu'est-ce que vous répondez là-dessus
sortir du nucléaire est-ce que c'est
vraiment possible parce que l'Allemagne
ne prouve pas l'échec de cette option
qui montre que non
je regrette j'ai écrit un gros rapport
qui ont trouvé sur le site de Global
Chance sur cette question de l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne a décidé en 2000 de sortir
du nucléaire
ça a été confirmé par la suite surtout
après Fukushima et l'Allemagne décrit du
nucléaire qui avait à peu près 20-25% de
la production d'électricité jusqu'à 0 on
a dit à ce moment-là mais c'était
épouvantable l'Allemagne baisse son
nucléaire et donc augmente le charbon
c'est pas du tout le cas
le développement des énergies
renouvelables en Allemagne ont plus que
compensé la la baisse du nucléaire
40 gigawatts de charbon aujourd'hui oui
ou non ils vont doubler leur capacité de
gaz c'est une réalité physique je suis
en train d'expliquer les réalités
physiques que je connais aussi bien que
vous probablement mieux et donc le
nucléaire a baissé les renouvelables ont
plus que compenser le nucléaire en
parallèle le charbon a également baissé
je regrette le charbon a également
baissé et aujourd'hui la production de
charbon
la production de charbon a diminué les
Allemands se sont engagés à fermer le
nucléaire ils vont le fermer
définitivement cette année avant la fin
de l'année et le charbon ils sont
engagés à sortir du charbon en 2030 et à
sortir du gaz en 2027
aujourd'hui il y a un attachement je
crois de nous tous de ceux qui nous
regardent des citoyens pour une filière
d'excellence moi je voudrais le rappeler
et moi ce qui me désole mais là c'est
vraiment la citoyenne qui parle on a
tellement d'esprit brillants en France
qu'on a découragé pendant des années
pardonnez-moi avec un avec un lobbying
qui est allé jusqu'aux jusqu'au sommet
de l'État en disant c'est sale c'est pas
bien etc après moi je ne remets pas en
cause ce que vous dites mais ce qui me
désespère c'est qu'on a beaucoup de
jeunes talents des jeunes Françaises et
Français qui ne sont blessés dans ce
domaine et franchement je vais vous dire
franchement ça me fait mal au cœur
tous ces talents peuvent s'exprimer dans
les énergies renouvelables c'est pas une
énergie du passé il y a de nombreux il y
a beaucoup de progrès qui sont possibles
autour des énergies des énergies
renouvelables donc moi je suis pour que
c'est à lancer exprime et il y a il y a
un futur qui est tout à fait possible
autour de ça concernant l'Allemagne
d'ailleurs je ferai pas parler que
l'Allemagne c'est l'exemple il y a
d'autres situations dans dans le monde
concernant l'Allemagne ils partaient
d'un niveau tellement haut et c'est leur
dépendance aux énergies fossiles mais je
voudrais le dire qu'est-ce que nous
avons voté pendant la loi pouvoir
d'achat en France la mise en place d'un
terminal méthanier la réouverture d'une
centrale à charbon pourquoi parce que là
on vit comme l'Allemagne une situation
difficile à cause de la crise
internationale du gaz russe donc c'est
malheureusement dans la transition pas
acceptable nous avons besoin du
nucléaire pour la transition mais nous
pouvons tout à fait RTE RTE RTE a fait
des scénarii 100% énergies renouvelables
ont
l'idée c'est pas de choisir entre les
deux c'est de choisir les deux c'est
tout l'intérêt des projets de loi qu'on
a discuté sur le sujet en même temps la
question de combien combien les ratios
c'est très important on va voir un sujet
tout à l'heure sur la fameuse règle des
50 % les sénateurs de droite ont décidé
de supprimer la limitation le seuil de
50% d'une nucléaire dans la part du mix
électrique il y a plus de limites au
nucléaire aujourd'hui en France moi je
soutiens absolument cette mesure parce
qu'elle était fondée sur des
considérations politiques n'ont pas
technique mais politique mais on peut
participer aujourd'hui la commission 90%
je participe aujourd'hui à la commission
d'enquête sur la souveraineté
énergétique qui d'ailleurs se passe dans
un esprit transpartisan qu'il faut
vraiment reconnaître de droite comme de
gauche on a des auditions de très très
grandes qualités je voudrais juste vous
dire très rapidement trois personnalités
de gauche
sur le sujet Arnaud Montebourg l'accord
entre le participe
extrêmement importants c'est un accord
politique de cuantables on va y venir
Ségolène Royal l'objectif de 50% est un
accord politique entre le PS et les
Verts cet accord politique n'est pas
techniquement robuste puisque
on va le regarder tout de suite ça sera
beaucoup plus simple pour qu'on puisse
les entendre cette fameuse règle de 50%
était-elle fondée sur une rationalité
scientifique ou pas vous menez l'enquête
notamment avec vos collègues députés
c'est un sujet de tibo-énocle
ce qui manquait jusqu'à février 2022
c'est l'exposition d'une vision claire
de ce qu'on voulait faire en termes de
politique énergétique c'est une histoire
qui court sur une décennie celle d'une
valse hésitation sur l'avenir du
nucléaire français de François Hollande
à Emmanuel Macron de 2012 à 2022 premier
acte la période socialiste au cœur des
auditions de la commission d'enquête
figure une loi de 2015 c'est elle qui a
prévu la diminution de la part du
nucléaire en France de 75 à 50%. cet
objectif je le reçois je suis censé le
mettre en application une loi qui
résulte en effet d'un accord entre le
Parti socialiste et les Verts avant la
présidentielle de 2012 un accord
aujourd'hui remise en cause par certains
pour moi c'est un accord de cuantables
c'est-à-dire qu'on s'est mis d'accord
sur un marqueur politique et on s'est
retrouvé avec un programme qui
expliquait qu'il fallait fermer 24
réacteurs les 50% étaient le résultat
d'aucune étude d'impact
ou analyse de besoins une absence
d'analyse de fond qui va conduire à
beaucoup d'atermoiements les ministres
de l'écologie qui vont se succéder vont
se retrouver prises en étau entre une
promesse politique et l'impossibilité
pratique de la mettre en œuvre pour
savoir si on est capable de maintenir ou
de baisser à 50 % la part du nucléaire
il faut d'abord être sûr d'avoir réussi
en matière d'économie d'énergie et
d'énergie renouvelable et au moment où
je suis voté la loi je ne sais pas si on
va réussir résultat pour résoudre le
problème on le dissout la loi de 2015
affiche l'objectif de 50% nucléaires à
horizon 2025 mais sans préciser par
quels moyens vient alors l'acte 2 le
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron le
nouveau président ne remet pas en cause
l'objectif fixé par son prédécesseur en
2018 il annonce la fermeture de 14
réacteurs l'horizon en est repoussé à
2035 mission toujours impossible rien
n'avait été prévu pardon de le dire
d'abord combien de temps pour démanteler
combien d'emplois est-ce qu'il y a des
reconversions possibles tout cela
n'avait pas été fait finalement seul
Fessenheim sera fermé avant que le
président ne perd une volte face
Emmanuel Macron en 2022 décide de
relancer un vaste programme nucléaire un
changement de pied que le gouvernement
doit aujourd'hui expliquer on ne
raisonne plus de la même façon puisqu'on
a maintenant une vision beaucoup plus
ambitieuse sur la réduction de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
donc sur les besoins de production
en électricité les travaux de la
commission vont se poursuivre avec
l'audition de François Hollande et
Nicolas Sarkozy jeudi prochain
c'est assez édifiant quand même c'est
ces témoignages d'anciens ministres cet
accord signé sur un coin de table dixit
Arnaud vous en tant qu'écologiste
aujourd'hui vous le resigneriez ou pas
alors d'abord peut-être préciser que
dans cet accord il y avait pas que la
réduction à 50 % du nucléaire il y avait
aussi une trajectoire de développement
des énergies renouvelables et que si
nous avions tenu nos engagements
là-dessus et malheureusement notre pays
ne pas tenu nous aurions l'équivalent de
6 fois Fessenheim aujourd'hui de
disponible on n'aurait pas regardé
l'hiver comme nous l'avons regardé avec
avec difficulté et donc c'est évidemment
il y a eu un accord politique mais je
pourrais vous parler je le disais tout à
l'heure de l'accord politique sur les
retraites d'une réforme très mal
préparée je pourrais vous parler de
l'accord qui se joue sur les 14 opères
on annonce 14 EPR au détour d'un texte
mais n'avait pas sur les scénario qui
n'avaient pas cette base technique je
suis
construire dès lors qu'on voulait mettre
un objectif c'était totalement refusé
c'est la loi de programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie qui doit le faire là
on va va vite c'est un accord au coin de
table entre le rassemblement national
en ville a été un fiasco il faut quand
même le dire et sur le coup et sur le
retard de chantier il y a quand même des
raisons s'inquiéter vous avez parlé de
traitement dans l'audit pas vous avez
parlé de trajectoire aucun ministre ne
réussissait à élaborer la loi de
transition énergétique pour la raison
simple qu'il était impossible de la
mettre en œuvre la trajectoire était
impossible à mettre en œuvre après
l'accordéon
responsabilités je rappelle que Manuel
Macron a fermé Fessenheim
donc je me sens pas nécessairement liés
de le défendre sur le sujet simplement
après des accords politiques qui avaient
été passé sans base technique il fallait
absolument se fonder sur des scénarios
techniquement validés par les sachants
de la filière il était évident qu'il
fallait avant de prendre n'importe
quelle décision politique attendent les
décisions de RTE RTE a publié 5
scénarios nous avons fait le choix de
équilibre plus énergies renouvelable
plus d'énergie renucléaire c'est sur la
base de ces scénarios que le Président
de la République s'est exprimé dans son
discours fondateur en la matière à
Belfort en évitant le fait qu'il fallait
mettre en compte
est-ce que la France a les moyens de ses
ambitions en matière d'investissement ça
va coûter 50 milliards sans compter le
financement ça va être énorme on sait
clairement ville ça a été quand même
très compliqué ça va être énorme mais
j'ai envie de vous dire le gouvernement
a dépensé
100 milliards et encore c'était il y a
quelques mois le dernier comptage pour
pour atténuer les effets de la crise
énergétique qu'on a connu cette dernière
année 100 milliards il les a trouvés et
c'est pas de l'investissement c'est de
l'argent comme ça versait donc la
question du coup elle est réelle c'est
celle qui va payerait sujet Comment va
les mobiliser l'argent sera mobilisé
j'ai quand on a besoin d'argent pour
aider les Français à payer leurs
factures on l'a trouvé oui mais ça veut
dire que les tarifs vont augmenter mais
les tarifs nécessairement augmenter mais
comme ils augmenteront également avec
des renouvelables j'ai envie de quand
même de replacer un peu les enjeux qu'on
perd de vue les fossiles ils constituent
encore aujourd'hui 60 %. c'est 60 % de
l'énergie finale qui est consommé en
France c'est 40% de pétrole 20% de gaz
c'est de ça dont on parle pas que de
l'électricité donc on aura besoin de
toutes les sources d'énergie propre
nucléaires renouvelables en plus
d'efforts énormes de sobriété dont on ne
parle pas assez on veut faire croire aux
gens que on va faire plein de donc il
faut bien avec la sobriété et là vous
avez le sourire de l'écologie de Charles
Fournier Bernard Bernard Laponche a-t-on
les moyens au regard du nucléaire
français que vous connaissez du fiasco
de Flamanville on peut le dire comme ça
qu'on a découvert les corrosion on a
découvert les fissures il y a le grand
carénage qui s'est ajouté on a dû
arrêter la production et importer de
l'électricité on se souvient des menaces
de coupure du président et du
gouvernement est-ce qu'on a les moyens
de cette ambition nucléaire deux points
le premier par rapport aux histoires
l'histoire de 50%
. c'était parfaitement raisonnable
pourquoi parce que actuellement
le système français tel que comme il y a
énormément de chauffage électrique on a
une pointe divers très élevée
mais le reste de l'année on y a une
surcapacité nucléaire par conséquent
avoir 50% ça assurer le nucléaire en
base et à ce moment là il fallait faire
des économies d'électricité
vu l'état du parc revenant à
l'investissement l'état du parc
actuel un parc avec 14 réacteurs
supplémentaires
supplémentaires ça n'a aucun sens
pourquoi
peut-on décider de faire des EP R2 qui
sont construits sur la base de la
conception de l'EPR et le Pr n'a
toujours pas démarré il devait démarrer
il devait démarrer en 2000 il devait
démarrer en 2012 il n'a toujours pas
démarré et il a des problèmes il a des
problèmes y compris de conception donc
tant que le Pr alors celui de Finlande
il a démarré un Millet actuellement
arrêté parce qu'il a aussi des problèmes
ce détail channel du pire pour la suite
c'est bien ça ni le pire ni pas le pire
il est impossible de prendre aujourd'hui
une décision sur un futur programme
alors
la commission quand même parce que
véritablement d'abord ça met en avant et
en lumière le travail du Parlement et
quand même il y a des auditions qui sont
exceptionnelles mais qui sont
exceptionnels par le elles sont
tellement édifiantes c'est incroyable le
moment où Nicolas Hulot ne sait pas s'il
a reçu un rapport qui est quand même pas
n'importe quel rapport et c'est ça
directrice rappelons-le quand même ça
veut dire la crise de cabinet qui doit
lui rappeler qu'à un moment j'appelle un
responsable politique il y a un moment
responsable quand même donc est-ce qu'il
a reçu ce rapport aussi important est-ce
qu'il l'a lu aussi sérieusement que ça
parce que c'est notre avenir qui est
engagé et quel que soit vos différents
et puis un mot la première ministre dit
nous ne savions pas à ce moment-là oui
mais oui la vision politique à un moment
il faut il faut y aller ça s'appelle la
vision un moment vous dites c'est vrai
mais c'est ça le j'allais dire le rôle
du politique c'est de nous engager sur
une voie en disant voilà allez par
ailleurs
en disant ce sont des décisions
politiques et c'est normal
ce sont des décisions politiques on sait
le problème c'est savoir qu'est-ce que
vous avez une base qui nous regarde
on va investir on va
y a financier d'EDF
mais il y a un énorme enjeu de vision
politique je crois le cap a été fixé il
y a aussi et là je partage votre point
un point de vision industrielle un
énorme sujet qu'on a évoqué dans la
commission d'enquête qu'on a additionné
c'est les enjeux industriels qui ont
fait qu'on a des retards extrêmement
conséquents et un surcharge financière
de la construction des EPR on a évoqué
par exemple le conflit majeur qu'il y a
eu et à une époque entre EDF et Areva
qui a été dramatique pour la filière
nucléaire et c'est tous ces enjeux là
qu'on étudie aujourd'hui dans cette
commission d'enquête pour trouver une
solution définir une vision politique
qui est fixée et ensuite aligner la
filière pour enfin rebâtir une filière
nucléaire d'excellence qui je crois a
été sacrée dans le pays
dans le sommaire
dira si on a tiré les leçons moi j'en
suis pas encore certaine en tout cas on
peut se réjouir de ce que le débat
public soit moins biaisé qu'il ne l'a
été depuis ces 20 dernières années on
parle un peu plus de fait et le débat à
venir sur la programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie justement et sur la part du
mix est très attendue et sera très
important justement pour qu'on puisse
établir collectivement ce diagnostic on
aura besoin de ce débat allez on fait
arrête là oui mais je pense qu'on a
absolument besoin de ce débat là mais on
est en train de le tronquer au détour
d'une loi on explique on va faire 14-6
puis 14 EPR on ne dit pas on ne dit pas
dans quelles conditions on va le faire
on a un vrai problème la loi en tout cas
sur les procédures et on a compris il y
a un grand texte de loi sur les
investissements qui arrivent et les
choix la vision on verra si elle est au
rendez-vous ou pas merci merci d'être
venu débattre sur le plateau de LCP vous
restez avec moi Sonia Mabrouk dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties pris de
nos affranchis ce soir le grand reporter
Vincent Huger va nous parler d'un
rapprochement diplomatique
incroyablement surprenant entre les deux
grands rivaux l'Iran et l'Arabie
Saoudite Fanny guinoche décortiquer le
CDI senior introduit par les sénateurs
sur les retraites et qui fera l'objet
d'appro discussion demain en CMP et bien
justement la commission mixte paritaire
qu'est-ce que c'est ce sera dans Bourbon
express avec Marco poliez mais d'abord
on va plonger dans votre livre Sonia
reconquérir le sacré aux éditions de
l'Observatoire le sacré dont vous parlez
le fruit d'un chemin intérieur il n'est
pas forcément religieux il peut être
civil et même laïque ça mérite une
explication regardez c'est dans
l'invitation signé ce soir par Hélène
Bonduelle
si on vous invite Sonia Mabrouk c'est
pour s'interroger sur la place du sacré
dans notre société
occidentale c'est l'objet de votre
dernier livre reconquérir le sacré
d'ailleurs plus que l'interroger vous en
fait l'éloge de ce sacré nous avons
compté au long des 144 pages le mot
revient 588 fois je dirais que le sacré
c'est ce besoin irrépressible de tout
temps de se raccrocher à ce qui nous
précède et à ce qui nous succède donc le
sacré c'est ce besoin de se raccrocher à
ce qui nous dépasse
Sonia Mabrouk vous êtes né en Tunisie et
vous êtes imprégné de politique dès
votre plus jeune âge votre oncle et
votre grand-père était tous deux
ministres du président Bourguiba
d'abord enseignant ta Carthage vous
quittez la Tunisie pour la France et
devenait journaliste au journal Jeune
Afrique avant que Jean-Pierre Elkabbach
ne vous repère c'est le début de votre
aventure télévisuel vous faites donc vos
armes à publique Sénat avant d'intégrer
Europe 1 et cnews où vous officiez
toujours aujourd'hui
France direct vos prises de position
vous valent d'être taxées de
conservatrices réactionnaire par les uns
de combattantes par les autres
essayez de vous éditer votre cinquième
livre en à peine 6 ans cette fois encore
vous questionnez la France mais
finalement l'Occident ces valeurs et
cette société désenchantée qui doit
selon vous se rattacher au sacré il en
va de sa survie tandis que l'Occident
connait un véritable hiver spirituel
c'est le printemps du sacré en Orient
un sacré qui serait tabou moqué ou pire
caché car considéré comme honteux le
politique s'éloigne oubliant qu'il y a
et c'est cette part moi que j'évoque
dans le livre un sacré qui est civil qui
est rassembleur dont ce livre vous
confiait aussi un témoignage personnel
votre rapport au sacré à travers la mort
récente de votre mère c'est lui qui vous
a sauvé dites-vous
alors nous avons une question Sonia
Mabrouk si le sacré est un chemin
personnel en quoi peut-il se traduire à
l'échelle collective
réponse Sonia Mabrouka parce que le
personnel a toujours Russell toujours
quelque chose d'universel alors en
particulier quand c'est l'amour absolu
la maternité l'amour d'une mère n'est
rien de plus universelle mais le sacré
quand il devient politique la plupart du
temps c'est de la nitroglycérine c'est
vous qui l'écrivez le recours à la
violence et récurrent dans notre
histoire alors comment on peut le
traduire d'un point de vue collectif
qu'est-ce que ce sacré laïque civil dont
vous parlez vous avez raison le sacré
c'est pas un chemin facile c'est pas un
chemin de rose c'est pas un chemin aisé
peut-être en quelques mots juste le
définir le sacré c'est ce besoin
irrépressible tout temps de se
raccrocher à ce qui nous précède et à ce
qui nous succédait donc c'est une
inscription dans la lignée c'est
exactement ça c'est il donne accès à
plus grand que soi à partir de là moi
j'ai toujours précisé en tous les cas
dans ce livre que le sacré ce n'est pas
le religieux il y a une différence c'est
quoi après c'est un sacré qui peut être
athée même férocement athée et même
républicain exemple
républicain écoutez dans tous les dans
tous les pays il y a du sacré parce que
dans tous les pays il y a des hauts
lieux de la mémoire nationale Le sacré
aujourd'hui s'incarne évidemment par un
panse je vous donne l'exemple du Mont
Valérien alors vous allez me dire mais
pourquoi en parler c'est de fait un
sacré républicain il y a quelques mois
on a eu des tags des inscriptions dans
ce lieu-là le président de la République
d'ailleurs avait dit à ce sujet souillé
ce lieu sacré de la République c'est
porté atteinte à notre unité et bien
voyez porter comme ça atteinte à cette
unité donner un coup de canif à ce sacré
ça mérite quand même qu'on réfléchisse
de nouveau à cette notion vous vous
amenez vraiment la réflexion vous ouvrez
ce terme mais en même temps le champ
sémantique c'est frappant il reste assez
religieux vous dites que le sacré vous
l'avez reçu comme la foi même si on l'a
compris c'est pas la même chose vous
parlez de conversion au sacré de voyage
intimes de voyage intérieur et même
d'apparition ses proches du religieux ça
non mais de toute façon il est très
difficile de mettre une frontière
étanche entre le sacré et ce serait
mentir de dire cela il y a une longue
tradition d'ailleurs même dans les dans
la tradition biblique dans la
littérature biblique le mot de sacré et
de 500 liés mais il n'est pas forcément
religieux moi je dis toujours qu'il faut
pas laisser les religions avoir le
monopole de l'administration du sacré
pourquoi je vous donne un exemple et on
le voit par exemple quand on se déplace
un certain pays ou certaines villes
Jérusalem vous avez une imbrication de
lieux saints qui sont autant de lieux
sacrés et bien vous voyez ce que ça
donne un choc des sacralité Mon Sacré
supérieur à ton sacré alors que dans un
autre État souverain laïque on peut
trouver un sacré de combat et donc à
cette continuité dont vous parlez entre
le religieux et le séculier pourquoi
vous ne parlez pas par exemple de besoin
de sens à l'échelle collectif
presque la même chose sans la dimension
religieuse mais la transcendance c'est
pas religieux pour moi la transcendance
est un ordre vertical qui n'est pas un
ordre religieux cet ordre vertical qui
échappe au plan dit maintenant mais vous
employez un mot qui est que je
reprendrai aussi dans le livre parce que
c'est Saint-Ex préféré il dit c'est le
sens des choses et en fait dans sa
fameuse lettre générale X il pose qu'il
est la vraie question que faut-il dire
aux hommes et il dit ceci j'ouvre les
guillemets rendre la signification
spirituelle les inquiétudes spirituelles
et faire pleuvoir sur les hommes quelque
chose qui ressemble au champ grégorien
mais il parle pas du religieux forcément
Saint-Exupéry il parle de ce qui nous
dépasse alors ce qui vous dépasse vous
on va parler de votre conversion
personnelle c'est par exemple la
cathédrale Saint Louis de Carthage vous
avez en Tunisie une forme d'épiphanie en
la visitant qu'est-ce qui s'est
manifesté précisément si ce n'est pas de
la divinité alors alors je vais essayer
de vous expliquer en quoi ce n'est pas
un rapport religieux pour moi c'est un
c'est un d'abord c'est ce que je voyais
depuis ma fenêtre enfant et donc je
c'est ce que je dis dans le livre à
travers vraiment les pierres de ce
monument moi je voyais les chapitre de
ma vie et j'avais l'impression d'avoir
un lien organique charnel avec ce
monument c'est une cathédrale et qui ne
l'est plus depuis un certain temps et
quand je suis allée la visiter un peu
plus tard il y avait des concerts je
suis entrée et je voyais les autres
personnes qui entraient mais voyez il y
avait pas de rupture entre j'allais dire
l'espace dans lequel ils étaient et dans
cette église et ce monument mais moi
quand je suis entré non j'ai sentais
qu'il fallait entrer avec une forme de
déférence parce que je sentais qu'il y
avait une limite une frontière c'est ça
le sacré il est pas forcément religieux
pour moi parce que ça inspire alors là
il faudra peut-être la restaurer mais
pour moi elle est magnifique ben ça
inspire le sublime s'inspire ce qui nous
élève et c'est pas forcément religieux
cette idée de transcendance alors s'il y
a une perte de sacrée c'est l'Occident
qui qui l'a perdu ce sens du sacré alors
vous êtes quand même assez sévère vous
vous dites que l'Occident est quasiment
des cadeaux à vous lire ni les style se
vôtre dans la surconsommation il se perd
dans l'individualisme on est à l'heure
de la guerre en on se bat pour les
valeurs occidentales la démocratie
et si l'Occident n'était que l'Ukraine
très bien mais pourquoi est-ce que pour
qui est-ce que nous serions capables
nous sacrifier aujourd'hui moi je pose
la question si nous sommes face à la
situation terrible et tragique connaît
l'Ukraine avec l'héroïsme la vaillance
qui est les caractérise nous verrons je
ne dis pas qu'on manque de courage je
dis que nous sommes quand même dans une
spirale nihilys individualiste c'est
difficile de dire l'inverse si vous
voulez qui nous mène myriam a une forme
j'allais dire de désacralisation parce
qu'on a sorti de nos vies le risque on
veut le risque zéro et quand on veut le
risque zéro je vais être un petit peu je
vais aller assez vite on sort la mort de
notre champ de vision vous voyez et
quand on sort la mort on dit en fait à
mort la mort je ne veux pas voir la mort
donc c'est une forme de puissance et la
vraie question n'est plus est-ce qu'on
est-ce que Dieu existe mais est-ce que
l'homme et pour combien de temps l'homme
va se prendre pour Dieu c'est ça une
société à travers les limites repoussées
du vivant le transhumanisme voilà mais
elle nous rattrape la mort elle nous a
rattrapé pendant le covid ah ben vous
faites c'est imposé
à nous mais encore une fois nous l'avons
chassé mais ça c'est pas de notre faute
par des mesures qui nous ont été
imposées je remets pas du tout en cause
les mesures du gouvernement mais
rendez-vous compte que quand même il y a
une rupture anthropologique à ce
moment-là nous avions malheureusement
pour ceux qui ont perdu des êtres chers
montrent en main 15 minutes enfin quelle
société peut accepter de se refaire son
deuil et c'est vrai que franchement
c'est d'une inhumanité terrible comment
avons-nous pu l'accepter et laisser
enfin des gens qui nous regardent vivre
cela dans une telle solitude là vous
êtes un peu plus difficile à suivre
soigner ma bouffe c'est sur la messe en
latin alors que vous regrettez de voir
disparaître la messe en latin ce sont
ces églises qui ne reconnaissent pas
Vatican II qui s'opposent à l'avortement
qui s'opposent au mariage homosexuel
est-ce que c'est ce que vous souhaitez
moi c'est la je vais vous expliquer je
cite la messe en latin et je cite aussi
mais là c'est pas pour vous faire un
parallèle le champ du musée c'est
l'appel à la prière pour moi c'est
quelque chose d'esthétique là je parle
de l'esthétisme parce que le sacré c'est
aussi un art sacré c'est le sublime
c'est le très beau et à travers la messe
en latin j'ai eu l'occasion de l'écouter
une fois et bien pour moi ça fait
référence à un patrimoine liturgique
c'est de la mais qui s'inscrit aussi
dans une histoire politique par rapport
au Vatican mais je vous rapporte en quoi
la défense de certaines positions je
pense pas qu'on puisse lier
véritablement une messe traduite en
latin à des positions rétrogrades et que
je pense que tous nous rejetons
aujourd'hui moi je l'ai à l'oreille
finalement comme valeur dans ce cas là
vous pouvez me dire
il peut y avoir des fonds
dans les mosquées et pour autant
d'églises en France encore aujourd'hui
où la messe se fait en latin en général
en général et ça n'est pas une règle je
ne généralise pas mais voilà il y a
aussi des options politique à travers ce
qu'il y a des extrémistes et des
fondamentales moi je non mais je
maintiens d'ailleurs je m'étonne qu'on
m'oppose une forme de on me dit oui mais
c'est ringard c'est rétrograde mais
pardon être conservateur parfois sur
certaines choses vouloir qu'elle perdure
qu'elle demeure à travers le temps je
pensais même d'une modernité mais c'est
totalement légitime je vais vous montrer
un dessin c'est dur d'être aimé par des
cons la Une de Charlie Hebdo qui a été
sacrilège justement pour beaucoup de
musulmans un blasphème et cabus a été a
été tué pour ça est-ce que ce dessin est
sacré pour vous alors ça c'est ce que
j'appelle en tous les cas je vais
consacré un chapitre c'est le choc des
sacralité et c'est pour ça quand je dis
reconquérir le sacré c'est-à-dire
reconsidérer la question pourquoi parce
que c'est de la dynamite si je peux dire
de la nitroglycérine vous voyez
caricaturez le prophète pour pour le
monde musulman une grande partie c'est
évidemment placement donc c'est une
chose sacrée ici en France chez nous
pouvoir le caric et en parler c'est la
liberté d'expression c'est même
maintenant le droit au blasphème et
c'est sacré mais dites moi comment
résoudre ce défi alors question et mais
c'est pour ça qu'il faut le reconquérir
et le reconsidérer mais moi j'aimerais
bien que le responsable politique aussi
se saisissent de cela mais il n'y a pas
de la hauteur quand Emmanuel Macron dit
qu'il y a une forme de transcendance
qu'il faut remplir ce cette place
laissez vide par la mort du roi que les
Français n'ont pas forcément accepté et
pourtant lui ont coupé la tête ça vous
inspire oui il a raison je sais très
davantage sa phrase qu'il a dit quand il
y a eu les inscriptions au monde valait
rien il avait dit que soyez ce lieu
sacré de la République s'est porté
atteinte à l'unité ça ne me parle plus
ce sacré républicain et voilà il m'est
plus proche si vous voulez que que cette
transcendance là reconquérir le sacré
vous poursuivrez en lisant ce livre la
survie de l'Occident passera par le
sacré c'est le bandeau aux éditions de
l'Observatoire c'est stimulant parfois
déroutant mais c'est passionnant merci
beaucoup Sonia Mabrouk allez c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos parties pris
nos affranchis ils vont vous faire
réagir et nous rejoignent tout de suite
bonsoir à vous trois Vincent Hugues qui
va nous parler pour l'international tout
à l'heure de se rapprochement Iran
Arabie Saoudite l'économie avec Fanny
guidochet bonsoir Fanny de France Info
qui va nous parler d'un CDI senior très
discuté au sein de la CMP et justement
la CMP c'est dans Bourbon express et
c'est une histoire qui nous est racontée
par Marco pommier bonsoir Marco bonsoir
Myriam ce soir je vous raconte
l'histoire d'un acronyme en trois
lettres qui fait beaucoup parler CMP
pour commission mixte paritaire demain
jour de mobilisation sociale et bien la
Commission va réunir ses membres à
l'Assemblée à partir de 9 heures 7
députés 7 sénateurs vont tenter de se
mettre d'accord sur une version finale
de la réforme des retraites 14
parlementaires que vous voyez à l'image
alors c'est un peu le Conclave du Palais
Bourbon c'est on peut dire oui conclave
c'est souvent le mot qui revient pour
parler de cette CMP rappelons quand même
qu'il s'agit d'une procédure courante
dans le processus légis Latif depuis le
début de la législature 14 projets de
loi on fait l'objet d'une CMP une
procédure qui se passe toujours à huis
clos en principe à l'abri des caméras
pour favoriser les échanges et le débat
sauf que cette fois et bien le groupe
socialiste a réclamé la vidéo hors de
question pour Gaëlle brun Pivet la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale une
CMP publique c'est non le règlement ne
le prévoit pas écoutez la réaction
d'Arthur de la porte
Arthur de la porte si elle brune pivée
dit qu'il y a déjà un compte rendu écrit
qui fait état des travaux de la CMP
pourquoi vouliez vous que ça soit public
alors je ne sais pas si la présidente a
déjà lu les comptes rendus de la CMP
mais c'est extrêmement succinct et ça ne
permet pas de rendre compte de
l'ensemble des positions qui ont été
exposées par les uns et par les autres
ni de comprendre les subtilités de ce
qui s'est passé lors de ces tractations
voilà pourquoi la nupes réclame plus de
transparence une transparence que
Mathilde panneaux promet quand même mais
à sa manière elle va siéger demain dans
cette CMP
nous on va utiliser ce que nous avons à
disposition c'est à dire à la fois
évidemment
nos réseaux sociaux notre Twitter et
autres peut-être sortir régulièrement
faire des points aussi vidéos live de ce
qui s'y passe en tout cas nous voulons
sortir
ceux qui se passe dans cette commission
mixte paritaire alors qu'est-ce qui va
sortir de cette commission mixte que
vous avez une boule de cristal Marco il
faut toujours être prudent à Myriam il y
a bien des points qui vont faire des
balles les carrières longues la surcotte
de 5% pour les femmes le CDI senior mais
au-delà de ces points de friction très
clairement le rapport de force c'est
favorable aux partisans de la réforme
regardez en raison de la c'est pourquoi
en raison de la Commission de scène cmpl
respecte à des équilibres précis chaque
chambre va envoyer quatre représentants
de la majorité et 3 de l'opposition
résultat 10 des 14 parlementaires
viennent des rangs de la majorité
présidentielle ou des républicains pour
la réforme donc seulement quatre élus
sont donc a priori contre le texte du
Gouvernement mais aujourd'hui on est
allé voir ces députés qui vont siéger
dans cette CMP regarder
cette CMP s'est jouée d'avance les jeux
sont faits il y aura un texte de
compromis avec le Sénat
tous ceux qui vous disent ça vous
manquent une CMP par définition c'est un
moment législatif très important pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'on va être à huis clos
pour pas être déranger à l'extérieur
Thomas ménager avantage aux partisans de
la réforme des retraites dans cette CMP
vous qui êtes contre et qui a les sièges
qu'est-ce que vous allez pouvoir faire
nous allons quand même essayer de
maintenir un certain nombre d'avancées
voter aussi puisque l'Assemblée
nationale n'a pas pu faire passer des
amendements à cause de l'obstruction la
nupaise comme vous le savez cette
commission mixparitaire sera conclusive
vraisemblablement tout est joué d'avance
il y a une négociation entre les
républicains et le gouvernement donc pas
trop de suspens je pense que pas trop de
suspense le suspense sera sur le vote du
texte qui sortira de cette commission
Miss paritaire
autrement dit le vrai suspense c'est
jeudi jour de vote le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale devront valider ou
non le très probable compromis de cette
scène plus oui l'heure de vérité
approche la CMP demain conclusive ou non
et sans doute un vote ou pas 49-3
comment vous sentez ça m'inspire les
choses pour l'inviter demain de la
matinale je pensais on reçoit Olivier
vérande donc oui là c'est un peu je
pense vous avez raison votre prudence
est à mettre en avant oui c'est une
vraie question parce qu'on me dit que
c'était un vrai suspense c'est le 49-3
alors c'est soit on y va au panache soit
on respecte j'allais dire on oublie à la
panique donc je sais pas le risque qu'il
est président de la République vous
croyez qu'il ira au vote même si les
ric-rac j'ai bien aimé l'expression je
crois que il a très bien défini pour nos
Retailleau c'est soit la grosse bersa ou
la roulette russe faut aimer les deux
c'est un chemin de crête entre les deux
voilà la Grosse Bertha c'est le 49-3 je
le dis au cas où on aurait pas forcément
fait l'association Fanny justement cette
commission mixparitaire elle va devoir
statuer sur le CD seniors qui a été
introduit par les sénateurs de droite
comment ça et du centre est-ce qu'il y a
une chose d'être adopté et combien ça
coûte ce CDI alors c'est le CDI de fin
de carrière exactement c'est ainsi qu'il
est intitulé dans l'amendement qui a été
déposé donc et adopter au Sénat
l'objectif c'est d'inciter les
employeurs à engager des salariés de
plus de 60 ans des salariés âgés avec un
contrat qui est exonéré de cotisations
sociales familiale en baissant en
enlevant ses cotisations ça permet
normalement aux employeurs de maintenir
le niveau de salaire de ses salariés qui
en fin de carrière sont plus
expérimentées et ont des salaires plus
élevés et puis l'autre avantage aussi de
ce contrat c'est de permettre aux
employeurs d'arrêter ce contrat sans
frais à la fin quand le salarié peut
faire valoir sa retraite à taux plein
pas besoin autrement dit d'attendre la
date butoir des 70 ans le gouvernement
lui est contre il en veut pas alors on
peut se dire pourquoi ben tout
simplement pour une histoire de coups
Gabriel Attal le ministre des comptes
publics a fait le calcul il y a grosso
modo 100.000 CDI qui sont signés chaque
année par des salariés de plus de 60 ans
et donc ça veut dire des cotisations en
moins donc grosso modo ça serait entre
800 millions et 2 + 2 milliards d'euros
alors pourquoi une telle fourchette
parce qu'en fait le gouvernement craint
des effets d'aubaine c'est à dire que
les entreprises qui auraient de toute
façon embaucher ces salariés
expérimentés parce qu'ils en ont besoin
profiter bien profiteraient de ces
contrats exonérés d'impôts et donc pour
ça le gouvernement met son veto alors
qui va emporter le bras de fer et bien
ça va être une vraie négociation qu'on
ne verra pas malheureusement en direct
peut-être qu'il y aura des flashs vidéo
après qu'est-ce qu'on fait mais ça va
négocier dur parce que les sénateurs y
tiennent ça sera un scalp qui auront
obtenu et puis c'est quand même le coeur
de cette réforme comment garder les
salariés plus plus longtemps au travail
2 ans les sénateurs voient dans ce CDI
de fin de carrière une façon de faire
passer la pilule mais c'est vrai
qu'au-delà de la question politique de
cette monnaie d'échange se pose la
question de l'efficacité et quand on
regarde il y a un certain nombre de
contrats qui ont été mis en place je
vais pas tous vous les faire mais on
peut penser au CDD seniors qui a été mis
en place il y a une dizaine d'années et
qui on en parle pas parce que il a fait
un flop total
le contrat de génération de François
Hollande qui était pour inciter les
seniors tout en faisant du tutorat avec
les juniors ça fait aussi un bide bref
souvent les contrats rattachés à l'âge
ça stigmatise c'est pas forcément ce qui
permet des vrais changements et de
d'inverser la tendance et puis dans
cette dans ce texte aussi il y a un
index senior pour aussi inciter les
entreprises à maintenir les salariés de
plus de 55 ans dans l'emploi alors si on
regarde par exemple là aussi
l'efficacité de l'index ég homme femme
qui veut être le modèle de c'est un ex
senior et bien là aussi il y a une étude
de l'Institut des politiques publiques
qui est sorti la semaine dernière et qui
montre que ça n'a absolument rien changé
ni sur le salaire ni sur la carrière
professionnelle des femmes et qu'on est
loin de l'égalité donc au-delà des
discussions politiques qu'on pourrait
aussi se poser la question de
l'efficacité des tensions
des fausses bonnes idées dans les textes
de loi merci Fanny on enchaîne pour vous
laisser le temps de réagir à ce sujet de
Vincent eugeux parce que je suis sûr que
ça va vous intéresser Vincent vous y
revenir sur le rétablissement des
relations diplomatiques entre l'Iran et
l'Arabie Saoudite ça a été une vraie
surprise pour le coup l'épisode
mériterait de figurer dans une
anthologie des rabibochages
géopolitiques les plus inattendues tant
l'animosité entre la République
islamique et la monarchie wahhabite
apparaît depuis des lustres comme une
sorte de données inaltérable de la reine
moyen-orientale voyons vous avez deux
puissances l'une chiite l'autre sunnite
se dispute aprement la suprématie
régionale voire une forme de primauté
sacrée on n'en sert pas dans la sphère
musulmane quitte à saper la cise par
tous les moyens du rival au prix ici
d'une alliance de revers là d'une guerre
par procuration alors souvenir personnel
voilà quelques années flanant dans les
rues de Téhéran je tombe en arrêt devant
une immense fresque murale la caricature
d'un émir ventripotent regarde torve
drapés dans une abeille à frappée de
l'étoile de David les poches lestées de
liasse de dollars
inutile de vous faire un dessin je viens
de le décrire aussi ancien quintense le
contentieux atteint son apogée en 2016
cette année-là l'exécution à riade du
dignitaire chiite niemeur al-immer
condamné pour terrorisme déclenche en
riposte le saccage de plusieurs missions
diplomatiques saoudiennes le conflit qui
en sanglante le Yémen voisin n'arrange
rien Téhéran épaule la rébellion outil
qui se permet de lâcher drone et voler
de missiles sur des sites pétroliers ou
des tankers saoudiens tand vol au
secours d'un gouvernement yéménite aux
abois en Syrie au Liban en Irak partout
on se livre bataille par protéger
interposés et le prince héritier
saoudien Mohamed Ben Salman BS relègue
le guide suprême iranien Ali ramené au
rang de nouvelles Hitler alors au vu des
relations de ce chant de mine à quoi
attribuer cette réconciliation d'abord
au principe de réalité comme souvent
Ryad étaithéran ont compris combien la
victoire par chaos relevée de la chimère
pure tout en mesurant le coût prohibitif
de leur guérilla ensuite à l'activisme
de la Chine bien sûr ce rapprochement
non dénué d'ambiguïté ou demeurant
résulte de deux années de tractations
secrètes menée de Bagdad au Sultanat
d'Oman via la Jordanie mais c'est bien à
Pékin qu'il a été scellé sous l'œil
bienveillant du ministre des Affaires
étrangères wanguy ainsi après avoir
dégainé sur le front ukrainien un plan
de paix en trompe l'oeil
du milieu confirme sa prétention au
statut de superpuissance médiatrice et
modératrice d'autant que ces ambitions
économiques requiert un environnement
stabilisé prévisible immunisés contre
les sautes d'humeur du marché pétrolier
donc la Chine grande gagnante de ce deal
irano saoudien qui perd de se
rapprochement j'envoie deux d'abord les
États-Unis naguère maître des horloges
du Proche-Orient et du Moyen-Orient par
un inconditionnel et jusqu'à la cécité
de l'Allier saoudien et c'est vrai que
sous la férule du 13 impulsif MBS le
royaume s'émancipe de la tutelle
américaine au point de refuser par
exemple en dépit des injonctions venus
de Washington d'accroître sa production
d'or noir pour en quelque sorte
desserrer l'emprise énergétique de
Moscou n'oublions pas au passage que le
chinois si j'ai une pine fut le premier
leader d'envergure à recevoir le prince
rouge MBS après l'assassination ordre
dans l'enceinte du consulat saoudien
d'Istanbul du dissident Jamal rachodji
deuxième perdant Israël obsédé par le
péril nucléaire iranien l'État hébreu
avait misé sur une normalisation
volontariste
avec les monarchies du Golfe histoire de
forger à une sorte de front antimola la
stratégie apporté ses fruits c'est vrai
avec les Émirats ou avec Bahreïn n'est
pas avec Riad et la fuite en avant
coloniale du cabinet de Benyamin network
de la saborder pour de bon
allez donc c'est inquiétant c'est de se
rapprochement vous surprend-t-il est-ce
qu'il va vous inquiète j'écoute toujours
et je lis et j'écoute avec grande
attention Vincent mais ce que je note
c'est
c'est comment dire aujourd'hui c'est
présence géopolitique et c'est Gobi twin
donc la Chine pour pour ce cas qui est
évidemment très emblématique
symptomatique et très révélateur la
Turquie avec ce qui s'y passe aussi pour
l'Ukraine et puis la Russie en Afrique
donc voilà trois pôles aujourd'hui
finalement qui ont alors c'est pas la
main mise Vincent mais qui quand même
qui ont un rôle considérable
exceptionnelles et qui vont voilà avoir
des conséquences très très importantes
aujourd'hui
le cerveau du monde à deux hémisphères
un or et en sud et il y a quand même un
vrai péril d'hémiplégie chez nous
occidentaux d'oublier que le magister
d'influence il ne fonctionne pas
toujours quand on n'est pas capable
d'aller accrocher les opinions et les
élites par exemple en Afrique ou au
Moyen-Orient il va de soi pour nous que
l'agression militaire russe en Ukraine
si les montants
doit être combattu et dénoncé et on
reste perplexe quand par exemple des
tours d'un vote onusien on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a un nombre significatif de pays
du Sud qui ne nous suivent pas là-dessus
on a encore un logiciel à revoir de se
rapprochement au-delà de la diplomatie
parce que au fond c'est un joli coup
pour la Chine une pierre dans le jardin
américain c'est clair mais la rivalité
demeure elle est profonde pour avoir
beaucoup sillonner cette région je l'ai
souvent touché du doigt merci beaucoup
merci
pour vos éclairages les affranchis merci
Sonia Mabrouk d'être venu sur le plateau
reconquérir le sacré c'est-à-dire aux
éditions de l'Observatoire le sacré la
transcendance ou pourquoi même pas le
sens tout simplement peut-être avec un
sens des choses Saint-Exupéry merci à
vous à tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire avec Jean-Pierre Gratien
bien sûr quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain même lui-même très belle soirée
[Musique]